let's see my sequences
[Applause]
thank you
let me welcome
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
thank you for joining us here
today uh le canada et an alie
anami
canada is an ally a partner precious
partner
and we like being the guarantors of
human rights
and other values that we share
between the european union and canada
has
withstood the test of time
and only grows
stronger geography may divide us but
there is no ocean that can part our
shared values
shared outlet outlook and shared way of
life
through our strategic partnership and
the comprehensive economic and trade
agreement
our privileged relationship has reached
new heights
but today we are facing a threat
to all of us
we did not provoke putin's illegal
invasion of ukraine
we did not invite this confrontation
between peace and war but we share a
commitment to solidarity with ukraine
and the millions of people forced to
flee putin's bombs
there is so much at stake and no one
knows this better than canada that is
home to one of the largest ukrainian
communities in the world
the core values that we all share are
under attack and the democratic world
order and the peace we have known is
under threat scenes that we thought were
confined to the dark chapters of our
history books have returned
the fight of the ukrainian people is a
fight for freedom democracy and our way
of life we cannot
leave them alone and we will not leave
them alone
with millions forced to flee the world
is again staring at an ever worsening
humanitarian crisis that we must be
ready and we must be willing to face
canada is a world leader in welcoming
and resettling people in search of a way
of life from horror and we must rely on
your expertise and your solidarity now
again it is really time to come together
now like never before
whatever it takes means continuing to
match massive sanctions with aid
military equipment and financial support
but it must also mean real humanitarian
corridors
urgent relocation
air bridges and a redoubling of efforts
to seek a ceasefire that is the response
that all our citizens whether in canada
or europe expect
and that is the response worthy of our
place in history this is our
generation's moment to prove that we can
live up to the promise of the world we
inherited
we can give ukrainian children women and
men
a chance at a future without fear but we
can only do it if the world acts
together so dear prime minister trudeau
thank you for being here with us for
reaffirming your great country's
commitment to democracy to equality to
multilateralism and to canada's proud
record of defending our shared humanity
prime minister the floor is yours
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you president mitzola
chairman mcallister of the committee on
foreign affairs president
delegation
canada distinguished parliamentarians
ladies and gentlemen
it is a privilege to be here in brussels
with you all
before starting i would initially like
to express my condolences following
the passing of presidents of solely at
the start of this year this is a massive
loss for your parliament and for europe
i would also like to take a moment to
express my condolences to
the families of the victims of the
tragedy in le louisville
and all those whose lives have been
turned upside down on that day
thoughts are with belgium at these
difficult times
i first addressed the eu parliament in
strasbourg
in 2017.
it was the first time a canadian prime
minister addressed your parliament
back then
this parliament saw me as someone new on
the world stage
we got to work
tackling progressive issues
building the things that we thought
mattered
we could see that something was lurking
off on the horizon something shadowy
something that was threatening
we didn't look close enough
[Music]
when i spoke to this parliament five
years ago
i spoke about making multilateralism
work for the middle class and those
working hard to join him
so that economic frustrations don't
become fertile ground for populism
nativism
protectionism
and the polarization towards
more extreme political views
well today
we're staring these forces in the face
as they threaten the peace justice truth
democracy and stability
of our world
and we have a choice
about what we do next
since 2017
the world has changed
a lot
a global pandemic
has taken the lives over of over 6
million people and disrupted
the lives of everyone else
a global recession
saw millions lose their jobs with many
economies still struggling to bounce
back
a world
that is not just now forecasting
but living
the dangers of climate change
a growing distrust of
governments
and facts
a weakening of democratic institutions
we saw
one of our staunchest guarantors of the
rules-based order
choosing for four years to step away
from nato away from multilateralism
and now
putin's
criminal invasion
of a sovereign
independent
democratic ukraine
people
have a real and deep sense of
uncertainty
about what the future holds
these are anxious times and people are
looking for leadership
and solutions
unfortunately
we're seeing a rise in
cynical populists who are trying to
exploit these anxieties
they pretend
to have easy solutions
that play on people's fears
even in canada
where ninety percent of people are
vaccinated and our motto as a country is
peace order and good government
we saw anti-vaccine and anti-government
protests devolve into
the leaders of those convoys
were effective
in turning citizens with real anxieties
against the system best suited to allay
those concerns
but democracy
isn't a game
and there just aren't
easy solutions
to the big complex problems we are all
facing
but that doesn't mean that the way
forward isn't clear
there is no greater clarity
than the will of the people who want
better for themselves and their children
at home and no stronger defense against
destructive forces from the outside
from outside our democracies
than
the unwavering unity
of like-minded partners
over the past 80 years
together
we have established and bolstered a
series of rules and institutions in
order to increase stability and
provisibility
for international affairs
and we did this to protect people
to provide for them the best prospects
for peace to defend their dignity
and their inalienable rights
and in order to make sure that they be
free to choose their own future
today
these rules and institutions
are being
threatened publicly
vladimir putin
has violated the most fundamental
principles of international law
and he is now killing innocent civilians
by bombing hospitals and residential
buildings
this flagrant contempt
for
laws and for human life constitutes a
huge threat for europe
but also for the world
the eu
and all of our partners and allies
are facing a defining moment
we
cannot
fail
we must meet
this moment
so i speak to you today
no longer is someone quite so new
in fact i
may now be one of the longest serving
longer serving progressive leaders
around
and i'm certainly not going to pretend
to have all the answers
but what i do know
is that there is
work
that lies before us as thoughtful
leaders
as people focused on the short and
long-term well-being of all our citizens
as people committed to democracy
and the values that underpin them
and that work
is more important than ever
putin
thought democracy was weak
he saw our disagreements and debates as
weakness
but what he has never understood
is that the rigors of debate
that
forceful civic engagement
is what makes us strong
and that democracy
at its best
will
always be stronger than authoritarianism
but if we're going to be honest
and we need to be honest in this place
we haven't always been
at our best
these past years
putin thought we were divided
he thought he could weaken the eu and
nato
he miscalculated
and he is seeing it backfire
nato and the eu are now more resolved
and united
than ever
because all of us in this room
who are committed to democracy
know in our bones
that democracy didn't happen by accident
and it will not continue without
deliberate
mindful
effort
[Applause]
my friends let me be clear
the europeans including our allies in
eastern europe can count on the
friendship
and the total support of canada
canada
is heading the advance forward presence
of tactical nature in
latvia for nato there are 10 countries
of nato coming together under that
mission for five years now hundreds of
canadian soldiers have been deployed
thousands of miles away from their homes
to be placed just a couple of hundred
kilometers from the russian border they
are deployed in latvia because what is
important for the security of europe
is also important for the security of
canada
recently we announced that we would be
doubling our deployment to nato in the
years to come
and these soldiers are not just
defending latvia and eastern europe they
are defending our freedom
our security and all of our democracies
we can
not let ukraine down
[Music]
[Applause]
they are counting on us
so let's use all the tools we have at
our disposal
president zielinski and i have been
talking often about the strong ties
between our countries
canada as mentioned is home to the
second largest ukrainian community in
the world
after russia
so we must all collectively step up to
provide humanitarian aid to support
families affected by this war
and already start thinking about
investing to rebuild
ukraine afterwards
we must all continue to send military
equipment and lethal aid to help
ukrainians in their heroic defense not
just of their lands
but of all of the principles that defend
ours
and we must continue to impose
unprecedented
sanctions on putin and his enablers in
russia and belarus increasing the
pressure as much as we can we must
ensure that the decision to invade a
sovereign independent country is
understood to be a strategic failure
that carries with it ruinous
costs for putin and russia
[Applause]
putin's attack on ukraine is an attack
on the values that form the pillars of
all democracies
we have a responsibility
to make the case to people about why
these values matter so much
not just to ukrainians
but to us all
we must recommit ourselves to the work
of strengthening our democracies
and demonstrate
the principled leadership
citizens everywhere are looking for
that leadership
means reinforcing the things our
citizens have in common
rather than playing to their differences
the task before us
is not small
but given the right tools
we can do it
and we should all be reassured of
how much of this work
is already underway
in this place and in parliaments like it
across europe and around the world
in canada
our government is in the process of
putting forward a legislative proposal
to counter internet crime
and this year canada is assuming the
presidency of the coalition for online
freedom and we are going to continue to
underscore the protection of the rights
of people inclusion and diversity
online here in the european union your
motto is
united in diversity
in canada diversity is also at the very
heart of who we are
of course we are aware that there is
always more work that can be done
but when it comes to the issue of a
reconciliation plan for indigenous
people to fight against systemic racism
for equality
genders
for the defense of lgbtqi
communities we are making progress
whether it be assuring the
implementation of the united nations
declaration
on the rights of indigenous peoples or
investing in supporting entrepreneurs in
communities of color we are giving the
tools for economic growth for those who
are often left in the lurch
can
and should
play a positive role in people's lives
in canada like in many european
countries
we made massive investments to respond
to the covet 19 pandemic
it was the right thing to do
to protect our people and it was the
necessary thing to do to ensure a strong
and robust economic recovery
because we know that when we invest in
people including in the most vulnerable
and when we grow the middle class and
make life more affordable for everyone
not only
do individuals benefit
but our entire country
and the foundations of our democracy
also
benefit
because
whether there be immediate consequences
of lack of food
security
inflation high prices for fuel or the
longer consequences of
climate change or the pandemic
democracies have to be at their best
to be able to
hold those difficult necessary
conversations with their citizens to
find the right solutions
and once when it comes to the fight
against climate change collaboration
between canada and the european union
will continue to be essential
[Music]
our work will continue to accelerate our
tradition our transition sorry but
towards green energy renewable energy
respecting our commitments from cop26
securing our
chains of supply including for
critical raw materials and minerals we
have to continue to work together to
build a cleaner
a cleaner future and a more resilient
economy
european countries
also share the goals of reducing poverty
and inequality while growing the middle
class
we share aspirations
for a better
safer and cleaner future
progressive trade agreements like ceta
are helping our economies grow and
creating good jobs while protecting high
standards for workers consumers and the
environment
our ability to pull together despite
differences and deliver for people
really mattered and i thank you all for
that
with the longest coastline in the world
canada's shores
reach out into the atlantic pacific and
arctic oceans
and our connections with the whole of
the americas
is strong we're one of the most globally
connected partners at the u.n
with memberships in nato the g7 the g20
the arctic council apec the oas the
commonwealth and la france
we all have a lot of work to do
and collaboration
will be key
to success success towards building a
better future for our kids and our
grandkids
it will require constant efforts
but i'm confident that we
are up to the task
i'm confident all of us here today
i'm confident
in the resilience of our institutions
and mostly i'm confident in our citizens
and i can say that that
because of what i've witnessed over the
past four weeks
the resolve
of our united response to this
unacceptable invasion
has been stronger
than anything putin expected
and not just from governments
but from citizens in all our countries
it's that spirit and resolve that we
must take forward with us
the european union
has mobilized to defend democracy
and as always you can count on the
friendship
and full support of canada every step of
the way
also
together
we have to support
democracies around the world including
those who are most fragile and fight
against authoritarianism
thanks to providing more investment and
providing more committed leadership as
well
we have to provide support for
courageous people like president
zielinski and the those ukrainians who
are fighting for their rights
and we have to continue our work each
and every one of us
in order to improve our democracies in
our own countries
five years ago
we saw the storm clouds on the horizon
but today
we are clear-eyed
let us continue to fight lies with truth
fear
with facts
division
with unity
as long as we don't take our democracy
for granted
as long as we keep working
every day to make it better
as long as our partnerships are strong
we can be confident in the future
in the words of the lodi
light
will win
over darkness
[Applause]
thank you so much prime minister trudeau
for those powerful words and messages we
will now
hear from representatives of all
political groups in this house starting
with the epp group siegfried mauritian
thank you
madam president prime minister tudor
welcome welcome to europe thank you for
addressing the people of europe today
and thank you very much for choosing the
european parliament to address the
people of europe today
dear colleagues
canadian soldiers have fought for
democracy and freedom in europe
throughout the first world war
throughout the second world war we have
seen we have known we have felt that we
can rely on the people of canada and on
canada when it comes to defending
freedom democracy in europe and today
prime minister you came again to europe
to defend a european country and for
this we all in europe and all of us in
the free world say thank
you the
the partnership between canada and the
european union is a long one is a strong
one it is based on democracy it is based
on the rule of law it is based on
equality it is based on freedom of the
speech and now is the time for all free
nations to stand up in the name of these
values to be united and defend ukraine
because defending ukraine means
defending europe and it means defending
the free world
the rules that our western societies are
built on are good for the people and now
is the time to reject the habits and the
lack of rules on which the regime of
vladimir putin is based on now is the
time for all of us to say no to threat
to exclusion to hate to fear to
intimidation because we have all seen
that after the people of central and
eastern europe have defeated communism
30 years ago choosing
transatlantic values choosing the
european union choosing nato membership
both safety stability and prosperity
to central eastern european countries
and if this is what the people of
ukraine choose for their country it is
our duty as european union and as canada
to stand by the side of the people of
ukraine together this is the first and
most important thing that we have to do
to answer the call of the people of
ukraine the second thing is to be united
and i believe this is what citizens in
europe and in canada expect of us
because we have seen people
in helsinki in talin in prague in berlin
in paris in warsaw going to the street
in defending ukraine exactly as people
of canada have went to the streets to
montreal to hamilton to edmonton to
toronto and to canada in the past weeks
we have to be united this is what the
people expect of us and we have shown
unity already in the last weeks by
acting together when it came to
sanctions but i believe dear colleagues
i believe prime minister as you have
also said
we have to do more when it comes to
sanction maximum support to ukraine but
also maximum possible cost for the
russian federation we have to enlarge
the list of russian politicians of
russian business people and oligarchs um
enlarge the list of russian business
people and oligarchs whom we sanction we
have to tell them very clearly no more
skiing in the alps no more shopping in
paris or vienna no more sunbathing in
nissan or on the coast of europe as long
as the regime which they are supporting
in russia is invading a free country we
have to close loopholes we have to
forbid access to public procurement for
russian companies be private or public
here in the european union and also in
canada and we have to reduce our
dependency on russian fossil fuels as
much as possible and as soon as possible
we have to be honest and transparent
also to the people in our countries in
telling them
that
defending democracy costs but not
defending democracy would cost even more
now is the time for leadership it is the
time for unity it is the time for
defending the european values the
transatlantic values the alliances that
we are together in which have proven the
test of time they stood the test of time
thank you once again very much for
coming to europe today for speaking to
us to the parliament for showing your
solidarity it is always good to know
that we have friends in these times
thank you very much
thank you very much uh mr murasan and
now on behalf of the snd group i invite
iracia garcia perez to take the floor
thank you thank you thank you president
of the european parliament and prime
minister trudeau welcome to the european
parliament you find yourself here in the
heart of a european democracy
which is yours as well because it was
built thanks to the courage of canadians
which 80 years ago sacrificed
their lives on this continent for
democracy and for freedom
1989 with the fall of the berlin wall
when we entered a new period of hope we
build we believe that we would never
return back to those times
we believe that we would always live in
peace
with multilateralism
without threats without nuclear threats
above all
now the criminal invasion of the ukraine
has changed the landscape
we find ourselves in a struggle between
democracy
democracies and autocratic systems of a
time
law that we thought to be long gone
the tragedy
of the ukraine
has led to canada the united states and
the european union finding a joint
solution
a solution
to the problem and a response much
greater than that of 2014 with the
annexation of the crimea and the donbas
we must do much more we must cut off
russian access to cryptocurrencies to
tax havens
and we must strangle those financing
connections that the different autocrats
have as well
and of course the oligarchs
so we have to work together to create
new ways to find the energy resources
that we need and here renewables will
play a very important role
now the european union will have to find
its own means in order to achieve this
with the help the concerted effort of
others
as well
in order to stop putin canada and
european allies will have to work
together meet the commitments that we've
made to the to nato with that two
percent of the gnp
will have to fight for democracy not
only with words but with actions as well
for a more of life of dignity
a transatlantic cooperation of
solidarity which will help us to
deal with the problems that exist and at
this moment of course the number one
problem is the massive exodus of
refugees
we have to
through this transatlantic alliance
create
that impression and let all know
that it is these types of structures
which guarantee democracy
now if we work together in a spirit of
unity putin will fail and his final days
will be spent in the international
criminal court
history has shown us that no war of
occupation no matter how strong the
occupier is
never wins
the spirit of 1989 will continue thanks
to the strength of this transatlantic
edifice that we have built and the
courage of the ukrainian people thank
you very much
and next on behalf of the renew europe
group i invite malik asmani to take the
floor
[Music]
thank you uh president mitsola dear
prime minister trudeau
welcome to the european parliament and
welcome to the house of european
democracy
as a member of our liberal family we
knew europe is particularly honored to
have you here in our midst
the west
is not a geographical place
it's a set of values and institutions
it entails freedom
democracy and the rule of law
we share this prime minister your great
nation and our union we hold so dear
we are partners and allies
bound to each other through history
tradition and share values
brave canadians have sacrificed their
lives on this continent defending our
freedom
because of putin's brutal war people are
dying on this continent once again
defending freedom and democracy
and this is unacceptable and together we
stand with the brave ukrainian people
autocracy is gaining ground
the end of history
has been postponed
autocratic dictators around the world
are trying to undo the rules-based water
order
they are threatening our way of life
democracies needs to stand firm we
should stand shoulder to shoulder and
confront this fundamental threat
together
transatlantic relations should be at the
core of our common stance once more
your leadership
and engagement has set a strong example
canada has stood firm with its continent
in a time of need and in need we find
ourselves once more prime minister
as long as putin does not cross the
golden bridge to retreat we need to act
swiftly with a firm hand
and act as one
peacefulness predictability and putin do
not go hand in hand
we see the world with new eyes now
and complacency is a luxury we can no
longer afford
whether in the arctic or in the baltics
our alliance must hold
we must work together to further isolate
putin's economy
we need to help each other gaining
energy independence so well so we can
stop financing putin's war
and we need to remain strongly committed
to our defensive nato alliance this also
means living up to the two percent
spending norm
this is a sensitive topic amongst many
many members of our alliance but i think
we need to be clear
freedom does not come cheap
and yes
this european union will need to step up
its effort to build a strong military
pillar within the nato
the eu and nato are not two separate
security providers we are both united
and complementary
let me finish the prime minister by
echoing statements made by your
government
we will not stand at lay by while a
nation seeks to erode in international
news that have kept us safe since the
end of world war ii
dear prime minister we share a long
common history we are partners allies
and friends
once again we face a common threat
once again we will shall stand together
as one
once again a unity
we shall overcome
thank you so much
thank you very much mr asmani
i invite now on behalf of the green
group ernest ultason to take the floor
[Music]
prime minister
welcome to the european parliament
canada has for a long time now been a
close friend and ally of uh europe the
european parliament and of ukraine so on
behalf of the greens group here i'd like
to thank you and thanks so many
canadians who've shown how clear and
determined they are by supporting
ukraine at this dramatic period
of course it's not just a war between
two countries but a brutal attack that
is against international law which is
based on democracy and not the strength
of weaponry
right as we speak putin is
committing war crimes in ukraine bombing
children's homes hospitals and we have
to support the reaction and response in
unity as we always have
prime minister europe and canada have to
work together in upcoming weeks to put
together an international architecture
based on international law and the
defense of human rights in the face of
uh increased threats from
authoritarianism of course to the
ukrainian refugees
helping those who are most in need i
would like to wholeheartedly thank the
canadian people for that
but here in europe dear prime minister
we have also made mistakes
putin fossil fueled war must wake us up
our energy transition is today not only
an urgency for for tackling climate
change but also a matter of security and
international stability
climate change is one of the biggest
threats that humankind has faced in the
last centuries and we need to act
urgently
also in canada prime minister where
fossil fuel infrastructure is still
being built
where net zero is only planned to be
reached by 2050 without any intermediate
target where tar sands one of the most
climate polluting sources of oil have
been expanded you may allow me friends
and partners need also to be honest and
frying to each other
our collective addition to fossil fuel
is a security risk now in europe and in
canada it is a destabilizing factor it
is a threat to peace and canada and
europe should urgently change their
course of action if we want to abide to
the commitments of the paris agreement
it's very good to be strong supporter of
multilateralisms as we are and believe
strongly multilateralism but we should
leap off to the promises then of the
paris agreement and move forward to
action it is our responsibility it is
your responsibility prime ministers
we are hundreds of millions of people to
build another future in europe and
canada
in the face of this brutal attack in
ukraine
in the face of an authoritarian black
backlash in the world let's work
together and let's work together not
building our societies in all
short-sighted policies but really based
on our common wish to live in a peaceful
world and an inhabitable planet thank
you again so much merced
thank you for your solidarity for coming
to see us today prime minister
soon
next on behalf of the id group marco
danley
grazie thank you thank you very much
president and welcome
prime minister tutor
thing
welcome to the european parliament
it's a wonderful opportunity for this
parliament to debate
about very important issues
the need of the west to provide a
coordinated and efficient response to
the russian aggression in the ukraine
this unity
uh this movement in concert
and with your inspiration of course are
very very
necessary at this point in time
so your presence is extremely important
here
a couple of years ago there was that
need in the course of crisis here to
work together on a transatlantic basis
an emergency not like that which exists
today but it was a different type of
emergency at that time and it requires
much greater if you like cooperation at
this point in time between canada and
the european union in order to deal with
the situation
the nato nato
as a structure as a force for peace
this is something that we have to look
at very closely in order to make sure
that we have that joint security
umbrella that structure
necessary to protect europe
zelensky
in his presentation to the italian
parliament spoke about the need for
protection and implicitly he called for
uh new modalities to be deployed by the
alliance in order to protect the ukraine
so
at this point
the moment has come
how will we respond in which particular
fashion will we deal with this
geopolitical crisis that exists before
us which unfortunately has developed
into
something much unexpected
uh the un resolution with the
condemnation of the russian invasion
in itself is wonderful but not enough
perhaps
numerous further steps have to be taken
so it's very important to take into
consideration what the conditions are
today as well as the resources which
this country holds
and
this
necessity that we have at this
particular point in time from these
resources
so undoubtedly these issues will be at
the epicenter of your debate and your
discussions in the days to come
major choices have to be made in a total
quantum leap and shift altogether of
policies
a new
future exists before us with new
models
a new multi-polar
approach perhaps necessary
maybe the west the occident will not be
at the
center of these new structures of this
new type of society that will develop in
the future
we have to look at the numerous
different solutions and possibilities
that exist out there and take into
consideration the protection of our
values of identities looking at the
social cultural political and economic
factors as well which affect the west
and we are proud of the
developmental model upon which our
welfare has been built
and our values our values which are
cannot be disputed in any way shape or
form and cannot be sacrificed in this
new
reality that will develop into the
future so i do feel that
your choices undoubtedly
in these very dramatic moments will take
into consideration the protection of
these values we need
western leadership which is robust and
strong and which will carry forward our
continent and its position in the world
into the future thank you
[Music]
grazie president
thank you madam chair welcome
prime minister trudeau
the uh ukrainian uh
prime minister of zelensky has said in
this house and other houses that the
ukrainians are really defending the
pillars of democracy which exist in all
of our countries and this is more
important than ever before today
so prime minister your presence here
today is very important it's very
valuable symbolically important the very
strong
connection and ties between your country
and the european union is so
important in 2014
the
your country has supported the
capital kiev and in the uk in the
ukraine and i think once again it is
important to underscore to uh clearly
underscore that we want to make further
efforts that need to be taken actions
that need to be undertaken in all the
right places to put an end to this
russian offensive
the russian ukrainian crisis has clearly
indicated that european union needs to
deal and invest in defense and in
security but also needs to renovate
and strengthen the cooperation with our
traditional partners such as canada
we're linked not only because we belong
to nato but also because of agreements
and bilateral agreements
european union and nato
never before
have taken coordinated efforts to
respond to the russian aggression and to
supporting the ukrainian people showing
the termination which is very clear
indeed so
we need to draw lessons from this to
face up to future challenges not only
from a military point of view but also
as far as
cyber security is concerned to
strengthen our intelligence and also to
fight terrorism and hybrid threats
the transatlantic relations and the
cooperation between the eu and nato
within the full respect of the
principles established in the treaties
agreed by the european council are
essential elements and we need to act
jointly
unitedly and complementing each other if
we really want to successfully face up
to the geopolitical challenges and the
security issues which we will be facing
up to in the future thank you mr fito
and now on behalf of the left group i
invite nikolai williamson to take the
floor
dear prime minister trudeau welcome back
to brussels it is dark times as you
rightly said
in my housing block we have now new
neighbors i met them the other day when
i was at the playground with my oldest
daughter
here we met misha and roma
two small
boys from ukraine at the age of eight
and four
together with their mother they have
fled putin's invasion
like millions
more
they need shelter they need shoes
and they need food
we need to stand together in solidarity
to help the refugees
that is why i am happy
to hear that canada will take an
unlimited number of refugees
taking care of refugees
cannot be a question
about numbers
it is about human lives
and human rights
i hope eu
and canada can unite on this
and i hope
our unity will go further
we need to strengthen the sanctions
we need to cancel the ukrainian foreign
debt
we need to support ukraine
dear colleagues we need to do our
outmost to support ukraine
it is clear that putin is exploiting
eu's dependency on russian on russian
gas
oil
and nuclear power
our best weapon against putin is a green
transition and energy
independence
it is not only about security it is of
course
also about tackling the climate crisis
before it is too late
mr prime minister
listening to the news
it is clear that there is an urgent need
for humanitarian corridors in mayupol
and the besieged cities
in ukraine
moreover there is a need to make sure
that putin and other war criminals do
not repeat the horrors that we see in
ukraine
we need to strengthen the international
order under the u.n
we need to make sure that all countries
have freedom and self-determination
mr prime minister
we need peace
not war
thank you
thank you mr williamson and now the last
colleague to take the floor is miss love
kolakuchi
dear colleagues dear citizens
prime minister trudeau
freedom
the right
of choice the right to freedom the right
to work
for many of us these are basic
fundamental human rights that millions
of people across the europe and across
the world have
given their lives in order to defend our
rights and the rights of our children
rights that we have fought for for
centuries
many of us including
me myself personally are ready and
willing to risk our own freedom and to
lay down our own lives
unfortunately
today among us
there are also those who want to trample
those basic rights canada
once a symbol
of the modern world
is under your
quasi-liberal leadership and over the
few
past few months it has become a symbol
of violating basic human rights and
civic freedoms
we have witnessed
women being trampled by horses
single parents being their their bank
accounts are being blocked so that they
cannot pay for their children's schools
they cannot pay for medicine they cannot
pair they pay their electricity bills
their water bills they cannot pay the
debts they have their mortgages
for you maybe these are liberal methods
but for
many citizens across the world this is a
dictatorship of the worst kind
be assured that the citizens of the
world
when united can stop any regime
that wants to abolish the freedom of
citizens whether by bombs or by harmful
medicine thank you
[Music]
that closes the debate thank you dear
colleagues thank you once again prime
minister for being with us and we look
forward to having you here quite soon
again thank you
this debate is closed we move to the
next item
you